[Musique]
oui toi alors qu'est ce que tu deviens
je suis toujours avec eric
non mais c'est incroyable ça fait quinze
ans que vous êtes ensemble 14 pour
l'achat d'un appartement un emprunt de
460 mille euros pour une durée de trois
cent soixante mans ses 25 ans c'est ça
le 30 30 ans non je dirais casino sinon
que moi ça m'a pas du tout une crise
d'angoissé mais je suis pas angoissé
[ __ ] j'y arrive plus voilà je fais un
break
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ok tu es un black out la première cuite
post-rupture classique
[Musique]
c'est quand même beaucoup plus rigolo de
se retrouver célibataire à nos âmes que
de rester avec quelqu'un comme ça va
plus c'est bien dans des ruptures c'est
en moyenne tu faire de talent qu'ils ont
envie de pécho technique aux gens qui
n'y connaît
sata la potasse
mais oubliez les gars j'ai tu devrais
dire merci un jour ça n'arrivera plus
tout le monde s'inquiète pour toi tu
célibataire je vais mal
[Musique]
comment